I always say chemistry is everything if
everything went smoothly all the time
we'd be very complacent and we'd stay in
one place one day at a time one hour at
a time don't get overwhelmed you always
hear that phrase up hard work beats
talent when talent or work hard nobody
knows what you can do but you we work
really hard we have a great show let's
just have fun create something in
quality that is really make a difference
in the marketplace we're all
extraordinary nobody's the same I cannot
tell you how many people try to talk me
out of that like please don't do this if
we tweet way beyond even befall you
still done so far she's an American
actress author dancer fashion designer
and singer she was the first Latina
actress to earn over a million dollars
from her role in crowd of sights
she's regarded as the most influential
Hispanic artist in the United States
she's Jennifer Lopez and here are her
top 10 roles for success at the end of
the day we took entrepreneur you're
talking about a creative visionary talk
about somebody
thus far to the business to everything
menu your ears smart enough to grab this
person who's great at marketing with
this person who's great at you know all
the different aspects of what you'll
need to make whatever it is your
business is to succeed I always say
chemistry is everything you know you
have to find chemistry with people and
the people that you have helps you with
it doesn't always work that first person
that you choose but at jobs like fingers
the people that come in you just you're
like wow stuff happens when we're
together you know and I've been lucky
enough to have a lot of people like that
in my life because I'm a Leo and I'm
very going oh I stay with those people
and we're going to build a building
building they can create and discover it
and keep challenging ourselves to be
better better better and what else what
other product product could we create
what other thing can we do for the
audience that's watching well Lou Anna
there's been many mistakes I've made I
think that that have bought me you know
mamee ler
I you only learn really in this world
from the mistakes you make from hard
times
from going through difficult periods
that's when you grow and we should look
at these moments as as opportunities for
growth and as almost blessings because
if everything went smoothly all the time
we'd be very complacent and we'd stay in
one place and we'd never ever stretch
ourselves or question ourselves or want
to be better people in a certain way but
these moments they force us to do these
things and and in those mistakes that I
can't just mention one mistake I think
of all so many things that you know
through my life that I go off that maybe
wasn't the right thing to do but if I
hadn't done that then I wouldn't have
known it wasn't the right thing to do
and so those things are necessary I love
what I do and I feel really blessed and
I always try to remember that because
like you said when I walked in here
you're like I you have so much going on
so busy now
but the truth is like I told you what
I'm doing downstairs with Kohl's is
something I love doing you know and
that's my thing and it's like how do I
make this work you know and how do we
feel that out and how do I give my best
to that and to everything that I'm doing
and it's just one day at a time one hour
at a time don't get overwhelmed it's not
rocket science I'm not curing cancer I'm
just entertaining hard work I think is
one important thing it you always hear
that phrase up hard work beats talent
when talent don't work hard it's going
to get both and I believe everybody does
tap town you got to find your talent and
then you got to work really really hard
and I distract to be the best and I
think those are the biggest keys to
success but the biggest one of all is
working hard you can't accomplish
anything if you're not in early and out
the latest which I use man nobody knows
what you can do but you nobody can tell
you if I tell you all the people who
told me I wasn't going to act or sing or
dance or I wasn't good at it or I should
stop or I should quit or even after I
became happiness you know for doing
these things you know I would be I would
be locked in a house somewhere doing
nothing
the truth is nobody knows what's inside
of you only you know what's inside of
you only you know what you can
accomplish and what you're capable of
and what your gut and your dreams and
your desires and your wants and your
ability you only know nobody else knows
so whatever you feel in your heart and
in your gut you should follow that
follow that and then if that changes one
day that's fine too then you follow that
but you're the only one who knows nobody
else Montreal
yeah minutes before you're offstage
ready to go on yeah where's that energy
level what's going through your mind
what do you think it ah tons of
adrenaline but it's funny right before
she like you know in the hour before
hours before a show you know it's coming
that hour before you get like that
adrenaline and you get like ready to go
but for me in the minute
in the seconds before the show starts I
get very very calm it's like everything
goes but this is her solo this is yeah
but it's fun and you know I haven't Rika
with me I did the solo stuff in South
America so that was that first night in
Panama for me was a bit nerve-wracking
but I was like and they have you know
I'm so funny we taped our prayer
backstage and you know and after the
prayer you know I was like you know we
just we worked really hard we have a
great show let's just have fun like I
had to remind myself like as much work
as it is and as much as I want to do
well and as much as everybody there
wants to do their best work and be
successful at the end of the day those
people are there to have fun you have
fun they have fun it's a successful
night you know and so that's what we do
stay at me pick what is next I'm Tori I
think it is anything it is kind of a
feeling but it's also a dedication to
creating one high quality product
something that's offensive to you and
your brand which is I think the most
important thing and something that is a
differentiated product as well something
that is only specific and not everybody
else is doing it in the same year
how do you differentiate that authentic
product of high pop do you find that
it's a combination of those things and
again my team with constantly
challenging ourselves whether is movies
or branding or TV a bookstore music or
whatever it is to to create something of
quality that is really make a difference
in the marketplace when did I feel like
I went from ordinary to extraordinary I
had to tell you that I always felt from
my parents that you could achieve
anything so long as you worked hard they
were like all about hard work and and
being able to accomplish whatever it is
that you wanted to accomplish like that
that was the idea that was put in my
head very young and um you know I don't
I don't I like these when they asked me
you know like what would you want to be
up there and they gave me a choice of
all these words and I said be
extraordinary because I feel like we're
all extraordinary nobody's the same
nobody there's no two people that are
like and honestly we all have the
capacity and we all have it in us the
ability to do whatever it is that we
want to do and all we have to do is kind
of just put our minds to it and and just
work hard and you can make anything
happen for me was never about money and
stuff like that was the last time I did
something crazy was it going to idle to
do that things are absolutely I cannot
tell you how many people try to talk me
out of that like please don't do this
yeah like this is like this is the worst
move you could ever make and I was like
you know what I don't think so it feels
right for my life right now
like just haven't had the babies they
were just starting to walk and talk and
really become you know fully functional
people you know and uh and I just
thought you know what they need
stability we've been traveling around at
that time mark was um
their dad was touring a lot and I was
traveling and it was just like you know
what this is gonna be a good thing for
them for me I love to
show and I just you know I just
basically said to everybody kind of over
all right I have to say Benny was kind
of on my side he was like what do you
feel like in your gut I feel like
business-wise for these reasons it could
be good but you have to feel good about
it and I said I feel like it's gonna be
a good thing I feel like I have
something to contribute I love music I
love talking about music I love artists
that's that's what I wanted I think this
could be a really nice thing and by the
way we only signed on for one year right
you know wasn't like a thing I was where
I thought oh god I'm gonna be here
forever I said no I'll do it for a year
and we'll see what happens I wound up
loving it so much I did it for two years
right you know and they asked me back I
was like okay taking risks for me has
been a big part of my journey just
thinking outside the box you know doing
the thing that everybody thinks is
dangerous sometimes and just knowing
that you can do it knowing that you'll
get through it thinking big it's
something I say a lot of a lot of times
when I get warm air I always encourage
my fans to think they think as big as
you can in reach reach way beyond and
even if you fall you still got so far
short of your goal you still have what
would so hi thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know which of JLo's
top 10 rules meant the most to you had
the biggest impact leave it in the
comments below and we will Jordan the
discussion and tell us to the your
favorite entrepreneur is that you want
Evan to feature in a future video leave
it in a comment tool thank you guys for
watching to believe and we'll see you
soon